Maksim Chmerkovskiy and Peta Murgatroyd
dish about Parenthood every day just
gets better and better and reveal Max's
brother is ready for a baby of his own
Val if you want one just just run Ichi
was with the newlyweds and their eight
month old baby boy as they posted up for
fame photographer and Getty and they
couldn't help but gush over their little
one first I gotta say baby Shia is
adorable
he's a little beautiful specimen we have
I'm so in love with him how has life
changed kind of in every way possible
weakly everything revolves around him
from the minute we get up you know the
second you was born it was just
responsibility yeah we both thought it's
like wow I'm living for this this human
everything is for him sona no have you
become more attracted to each other now
that you have a baby together now that
you see each other as parents what I
think so Oh before but am i hotter now
every day if this was real to begin with
and then something like a childbirth
makes it just so much stronger the bond
is crazy looking back you know I I can't
imagine having kids with anybody but
Peeta
obviously but what would I wish for
maybe having met her earlier and having
had kids earlier absolutely yeah me too
oh wow
seems like he's gotten a little bit of
baby fever does he like you think he's
ready for maybe his own I say yes yeah
it's gonna be hard no matter what age
you are or your financial situation or
where you live we grew up in a you know
tiny two-bedroom with my brother and
bunk beds and all that so you know and
we came out great
enjoying life and you know trying to set
up for when you can't have a child is
just to me it's just it's it's
is never a perfect time I just say do it
yeah like Val if you want one just just
just go around
[Music]